All right.
Well, using all the skills that you've
learned throughout this course,
it's time to make some final
tweaks to the home town site.
To start off, I want you to
update the sports score table.
Go ahead and put your favorite sports
teams in, and make sure it's responsive.
I've also added another column into
the sports score table just to
make things a little bit more difficult.
Next up, double check your text.
Is there any text that's too long?
If so, find a way to make it fit
a little bit more naturally.
This is also a great place to
add some minor breakpoints.
Add at least one, or
I'm sure if you keep trying, you could
find a lot more than just one to add.
Lastly, try replacing a few of
the images with responsive images.
If you haven't completed the responsive
images course, check out the responsive
images section of Web Fundamentals
using the link in the instructor notes.
And when you're done, make sure you
share your project in the forums.
That's the best way to get feedback and
make improvements.